Omar Sy de retour dans les Yvelines
l'enfant de Trappes réside aujourd'hui à
Los Angeles pour défendre un touchable
aux Oscars après un César du meilleur
acteur en 2012
merci beaucoup merci à tous
oh merci il est chouette moi je pense
qu'il est très chouette c'est le
l'enfant de Trappes
c'est un bon exemple en fait qui est
parti de plus bas il est montéo et voilà
qui continue
très bonne image il est super génial
très bien très contente qu'il soit sympa
mais voilà qu'il y a rien à dire ou
merci vraiment c'est un exemple pour nos
enfants du quartier ici le 12 décembre
dernier
Omar est donc venu à 50 ans en Yvelines
présentées son nouveau film à l'UGC de
l'autre côté du périph édition spéciale
du 7 8
tu vas me faire griller regarde ta tête
tu peux le picasser
bonsoir On retourne au soir forcément
ici revenir dans les Yvelines
l'avant-première ici c'était obligatoire
vous faites un périph tour mais de
toutes les dates forcément ici c'est
particulier forcément c'est particulier
de rappeler la petite histoire j'ai
grandi ici je vais au cinéma ici encore
aujourd'hui ce que j'habite pas loin
j'étais au lycée juste en face donc il y
a plusieurs choses qui se mélangent
quand je la et en plus j'ai des invités
qui comptent beaucoup pour moi donc il y
a tout ça qui se mélangent donc
le film de présenter un film ici ça ça
va le lancer c'est un test de voir si ça
marche chez vous en tout cas même si ça
marchait pas peut-être ailleurs en tout
cas chez vous ça a marché dans le
département une étape de fait c'est à
dire que si les gens qui sont proches de
moi
valides le film se content du film moi
ça me donne aussi la force et le encore
plus de force encore plus de courage
pour le défendre le plus possible quoi
une ambiance particulière dans la salle
parce que il y a eu un moment vous avez
tout le monde s'entend bien tout le
monde est content et puis juste derrière
il y a une question sur je joue un
banlieusard encore vous jouez encore un
banlieusard est-ce que ça vous agace
j'avais pas prévu de vous emmener sur ce
terrain là mais ça c'est dit dans
pendant la première et un spectateur qui
vous a posé la question
c'est pas le seul à me poser la question
c'est pour ça que j'ai déjà ma réponse
on me la pose souvent cette question
vous avez toujours envie d'y répondre ça
vous agacement parce que vous êtes
redevenu très très sérieux
c'est une question sérieuse c'est une
question importante donc quand tu es
sérieux et important mais les blagues de
côté j'essaie de d'y répondre et en plus
sincèrement parce que moi j'ai vraiment
ma réponse à ça est-ce que vous savez
quel est le premier acteur moustachi qui
est eu un César Jean Rochefort
c'est que c'est vrai que la victoire en
fait pour moi le combat c'est si s'il y
en a un c'est à dire qu'on aura gagné le
jour où être noir en France sera aussi
banal qu'être moustachu en France c'est
qu'on arrêtera un petit peu de signaler
à chaque fois j'ai quand même le
sentiment que les choses avancent dans
le bon sens
ça bouge voilà ça c'est qu'on vous la
posera plus au final cette question
c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite en tout cas
c'est le c'est le but c'est le but je
ferai tout pour je ferai tout pour pour
qu'on pose plus cette question mais pas
seulement à moi à plus personne
alors on fait pas de vagues on marche
sur des œufs
c'est cool bonjour On vous
dérange pas
très clair c'est comme un arc-en-ciel
mais de gris je vais te tuer
si tu peux me permettre petite faute tu
n'es pas votre place vous êtes plus
clair pourquoi tu me pourquoi tu veux
briser ma vie
alors on va parler d'Omar Sy et du
département des Yvelines toujours très
impliqué dans ce département des
Yvelines on vous avait rencontré en 2009
c'est à Montfort la Maury pour une
opération de solidarité pour
l'association et là c'était avec avec
Fred vous participez aussi à des
critères de temps en temps pour remettre
des prix des prix d'impro aux jeunes qui
participent pour autant vous avez jamais
vous n'avez jamais fait d'impro non et
pourquoi non je n'ai jamais fait d'impro
parce que
on est obligé de passer par des clics
théâtre pour pouvoir réussir ensuite
maintenant moi je suis passé par des par
Déclic Théâtre mais c'était indirect
parce que Jamel est passé par des clips
théâtre et ses Jamel moi qui me qui
m'embarque dans ses aventures donc
indirectement je dois quelque chose moi
un papy à des théâtre donc je suis
toujours très content de toute façon
même si c'est pour papy ou autre mais de
toute façon quand je peux faire quelque
chose pour pour trap ou pour pour les
environs je suis toujours très content
et surtout très fiers de pouvoir faire
quelque chose papier Alain de bois on
l'a reçu il y a pas très longtemps sur
le plateau de téléfil On a forcément
parlé de vous puisque ça coïncide avec
la sortie du film lorsqu'on lui a
demandé pourquoi
Omar n'était jamais passé il nous a
confié que homard avait peur de faire de
l'impro
Omar Sy il est pas passé par des clics
théâtre même s'il vient de trappes et
non et il est pas passé ce qui me dit
c'est ce que me disait Omar il me dit
mais moi j'avais trop peur papi j'avais
trop peur dans un bâtiment mais il nous
a toujours soutenu toujours été là tout
au long de
du développement de la compagnie de la
radio donc dans mars c'est un vrai
copain aussi puis il explique rapide
parce que et non seulement mais il voit
tous les matchs d'impro il me dit je
venais voir mais ça me faisait vraiment
trop peur aujourd'hui je pense qu'il a
un peu moins peur on va on va dire
d'aller se montrer peut-être
prochainement dans la patinoire alors
voilà
les tuyaux peut-être que j'avais peur
peut-être que j'avais peur peut-être que
j'étais trop timide peut-être bien ouais
peut-être bien c'est ça s'est découvert
en tout cas chez moi sur le tard que
j'étais pas si timide que ça ou en tout
cas j'ai il y a un moment où j'arrive à
le dépasser et éventuellement il nous a
dit que pourquoi pas de l'impro un peu
plus tard aujourd'hui maintenant dans
une patinoire donc qui est lieu où on
fait de l'improvisation dans une
patinoire ce serait possible avec Jamel
par exemple dans une patinoire je pense
pas je pense pas mais par exemple ce
soir dans la salle c'est de l'improvence
ça m'arrive d'improviser sur des
plateaux enfin voilà c'est aujourd'hui
l'impro je m'en sers a fait partie c'est
ça fait partie de mon métier mais dans
une patinoire j'ai jamais pensé en vrai
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas ce serait
l'occasion juste pour rester sur des
clics théâtre un mot un mot de 10 à
Doumbia parce qu'en fait il s'adoumbia
vous le connaissez
la ville il est aussi à la télévision
alors je regarde mes fiches parce qu'il
est partout à la télé il est avec Cauet
avec nos chers voisins sur TF1 lascar
sur Canal+ également il savait qu'il y
avait l'interview qu'on devait réaliser
ce soir je vais demander s'il avait un
petit message à vous faire passer je
vais vous lire sa réponse merci d'être
toujours là pour moi grand frère c'est
magique de suivre une étoile filante
qui représente ce rôle de grand frère
justement vous vous le voulez
véritablement amener emmener les autres
avec vous vers le succès vers la gloire
aussi comme Issa par exemple je sais je
sais pas
non c'est pas un rôle qu'on se donne
comme ça c'est un truc qu'on fait sans
vraiment réfléchir il se trouve que moi
Jamel il a fait ça pour moi il est il
avançait il tirait avec lui et moi quand
j'ai pu avancer il y avait Isaac qui
était pas loin c'est un garçon que
j'aime beaucoup que je trouve talentueux
est très motivé donc si je peux je le
tire avec moi j'espère qu'il fera la
même chose et on va faire une grande
chaîne comme ça et ainsi de suite je
trouve que ça je trouve ça plutôt beau
et puis c'est aussi comme ça qu'on a
l'habitude de fonctionner quand on peut
aider on aide en fait je veux dire il y
a
ça se réfléchisse ça se résonne même pas
en fait c'est un comme un réflexe quand
on quand on tombe on met les on met les
mains devant pour pas prendre le visage
c'est un truc qu'on fait sans vraiment
réfléchir c'est instinctif le renard le
buisson comme ça il a fait
chaque homme
il a pris la main droite comme ça là il
a tapé
le fromage ou le poteau le corbeau c'est
imbécile
mais impeccable qu'on ne lui prendrait
plus Mamadou de la fontaine des ouvrages
le film que vous êtes venus présenter ce
soir vous enjouez dans le film de ce
côté buddy movie des années 80 côté Axel
Foley la référence donc du flic que vous
interprétez
véritablement c'était c'était l'objectif
vous avez revisionné tous les films les
48 heures par exemple avec Nick Nolte et
Eddie Murphy aussi
en tout cas les références qui étaient
quand David m'a parlé de ce projet là
c'était les références qui donnaient
c'est effectivement 48 heures le film de
Beverly c'est le Night run etc mais en
même temps c'était pas non plus pour
pour faire une parodie ou d'essayer de
faire le même film c'était bien juste de
savoir où il voulait aller et puis c'est
bien aussi d'avoir de
d'essayer de retrouver de se reconnecter
avec le film sans le voir c'est là ça
devient intéressant ou ça devient de
l'autre quoi
il arrivera jusqu'à Beverly Hills il y a
quelques temps déjà que je suis pic mais
j'ai jamais vu une tire aussi bien
briquet les mecs
c'est plus chic comme un appartement et
dans la foulée il démasque un tueur
et comment vous savez que c'est un
professionnel avant conseil retourne à
des trois dans ton trouhaha parce qu'il
va t'arriver des bricoles
vous revendiquez vous assumez toutes ces
influences des films des années 80 48
heures par exemple c'est la référence le
film avec Eddy Murphy et Nick knold
est-ce que 48 heures ce film a dicter un
petit peu votre écriture aussi vous
l'aviez dans un coin de la tête toujours
48 ans
qui ont un côté très noir et un côté de
comédie et la communauté dans ces films
là vient uniquement de la rencontre des
deux personnages c'est une île souvent
et des comédies d'action tout est un peu
drôle les figurants sont rigolos les
décors sont sympathiques mais dans 48
heures dans l'arme fatale les décors
sont durs le jeu est très vrai c'est
vraiment la confrontation qui fait
jaillir des étincelles et ça c'est
vraiment pour moi c'était le parti pris
du fil
d'où l'idée est l'envie en tout cas tout
le monde ont des décors très vrais on a
privilégié que des décors très réalistes
pour montrer la réalité sociale donc le
l'humour aller venir vraiment de nos
deux personnages dans une réalité
sociale bien ancrée
Oussama il faut que tu comprennes que
j'ai absolument totalement pas du tout
besoin de toi je suis sûr que le
meilleur chèque de ta banlieumes ici
c'est Paris c'est Paris mon vieux et
pire c'est limité arrondissement la
capitale de Paris alors on fait pas de
vague où tu vas
bonjour
tu peux venir toi aussi
il y a de l'action aussi il y a beaucoup
il y a de la comédie d'action pour de
vrai la comédie vous savez faire sans
problème l'action ça a été dur l'action
c'était difficile j'ai sous-estimé le
côté action c'est-à-dire courir courir
tout le temps faire les prises et c'est
garder la même intensité quand ça se
battait avec Maxime tout ça c'était des
scènes très très physique
prochain film d'action je pense
physiquement je me préparais mieux
dernier mot la première télé c'était
TVfil 78 les premières images
éventuellement il paraît que la fin du
monde c'est programmé pour le 21
décembre c'est peut-être la dernière
télé là ce soir ce sera TVfil le mot de
la fin c'est quoi alors ça serait la
boucle bouclée merci beaucoup
tu as ton sujet ton sujet